ocean waves is a studio ghibli film you
may never have heard of this film was
originally shown on Japanese television
in 1993 and it has taken until now for
it to get an official release in the
United States of America
similar to only yesterday which was
another Studio Ghibli film that never
saw release in the States until last
year this film is finally getting
released thanks to G kids who also gave
me a screener link to watch this film
early and I got to see it officially
I've never watched the bootleg that's
been available for years or the UK
blu-ray I have waited for an official US
release to actually get to see this film
and I did this film is about a young man
who has been in college for a while and
he returns home to recall his past life
his high school years where he first met
a girl who was incredibly stubborn who
really ran him up the wall and he begins
to wonder if he actually has more
feelings for this girl than he thought
he originally did and similar to only
yesterday it's told through flashbacks
and sometimes goes back to the present
where he's wondering if maybe there was
something he missed out on in life and
if he could still have it now only
yesterday took forever to come to
America because it explored the
blossoming of womanhood a little bit in
a scene and I think Disney was like oh
well we can't show children that and so
it took forever this film is not one of
Studio Ghibli's best efforts it was made
by young animators it was one of the
first Studio Ghibli films that wasn't
directed by Hayao Miyazaki or east out
Takahata and they wanted to give the
young animators who work at Studio
Ghibli a chance to show their colors and
so we have this television movie that
looks pretty damn good for a television
movie from 1993 the story is a little
meaningless the musical score is
noticeably more symphonic than some of
the grand orchestral arrangements that
Studio Ghibli films normally get and the
animation also is of a lower budget
nature than Studio Ghibli it's
theatrical films but that's to be
expected because this movie was made for
Japanese television this is not a great
film there is some issues that I have
with ocean waves and largely they're due
to the characters in this movie this
film heavily heavily relies on nostalgia
and
wants us to be able to connect with
these characters and look back in our
past and remember embarrassing things
that we did in high school or how we
treated others and if we were treating
people properly or improperly and it's
relying on us to connect with the
characters and the events in this film
and go oh man I remember that now I have
a personal connection with this movie
this film is largely about this boy and
this girl and how incredibly rude and
mean she is I mean she treats this kid
awfully there's a scene where they both
slap each other back-to-back and so
they're already abusive physically and
verbally and it's kind of hard to latch
onto these kids and that's one of my
biggest issues with ocean waves it's a
film that has characters that just I
can't really relate to and you're trying
to because it's well animated and there
are some sweet touching moments but
overall I can see why it's taken this
long for this film to be released
because when you compare it to Studio
Ghibli's other films in their Canon it
doesn't even hold a candle to them and
it does feel sort of inconsequential
when the film ends because you don't
really build up that much investment in
their relationship because throughout
the entire film they're arguing she's
incredibly mean you learn about her past
and that she's dealt with a lot of
problems with her family and some of
these social issues that she has dealt
with have caused her to become like this
and so you feel some sympathy for her
but when she's like that for almost the
entire film it's tough to really
understand why these two would even work
together because before they even
officially act like they're dating
they're literally hitting each other and
that's not really that good but there is
still a quality of ocean waves that I
appreciated beyond the animation and the
studio ghibli look and the novelty of
finally seeing this film after waiting
for so many years that's the fact that
some of the nostalgic elements that are
meant to make you recall your own past
kind of did and there were moments where
I was like oh man you know I really feel
that I remember moments like that in my
own personal life and so there were
times in this movie that I connected
with its story but in the end it's kind
of a frustrating experience because it
will go from slightly making you a
little compel
with these characters - focusing on
something else that is just sort of
they're almost to beef up the runtime
for network television all in all I
think Studio Ghibli purists like myself
who want to see the entire filmography
of this studio should check out this
film but if you're just a casual anime
watcher then this is definitely going to
be more towards the bottom of the barrel
in regards to anime romances I'm going
to give own waves a C+ not a bad film at
all but disappointing in regards to
Studio Ghibli other films I really
appreciate the fact that G Kids has
finally made it available for us in the
United States it's going to be expanding
all throughout the beginning of 2017 in
the theaters across the US and if you're
in New York I believe December 28th is
when you can see it at the IFC Center
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to a lot of
reviews I'm doing a lot of oscar
qualifying type movie reviews right now
I had a chance to see a lot of screeners
that gratefully are helping me out thank
you so much guys for watching and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you